Всім привіт з Верховної Ради оце місце
на якому знаходиться президент коли
приходить в Верховну Раду На жаль робить
Він це рідко тому мені довелось
звернутись до нього офіційно з вимогою
що я хочу з ним зустрітися я маю таке
право по закону України Про статус
народного депутата на зустріч з
будь-яким керівником в Україні по
питаннях депутатської діяльності і в
мене є багато питань Я перелічу тільки
декілька з них демобілізація мій
законопроект про демобілізацію після 18
місяців служби вже більше півроку в
парламенті Давайте говорити про це наші
воїни та сталеві люди все але навіть
метал втомлюється ну не може бути таке
що вхід є виходу немає тільки двосотним
чи трьсотним що війна є для одних а інші
навіть не хочуть про це чути так не
буває маса питань По виплатах по
лікуванню по отримуванн статусу учасника
бойових дій ту повний Бардак і це треба
негайно вирішувати